el único óxido de zinc común tiene la
fórmula zeta en el zinc y luego tenemos
el oxígeno escribe la configuración
electrónica para un átomo de zinc en
estado fundamental bueno hay un par de
formas en las que podemos hacer esto
para la configuración electrónica
primero vamos a identificar el zinc en
nuestra tabla periódica de los elementos
de hecho esta es la que les dan en el
examen de nivel avanzado entonces aquí
tenemos el zinc y hay un par de formas
en que podemos sacar la configuración la
más simple es empezar con el gas noble
que se encuentra antes del zinc que
sería el argón entonces podemos decir
que tiene la misma configuración
electrónica del argón
argón
déjenme ver es la misma configuración
del argón pero después hay que agregar
electrones a la sub capa 4s y tenemos 4
s 14 s 2 entonces argón y luego 4 s 2
y después voy a simplificar mucho las
cosas con lo que voy a decir pero cuando
deducimos las configuraciones
electrónicas es muy útil que después de
llenar la sub capa s pensemos en
regresar es decir que ahora vamos a
llenar la sub capa 3 de entonces 3 de 13
de 23 de 33 de 4 3 de 5 6 7 8 9 10
entonces 4 s 23 de 10 3 de 10
y hay dos excepciones en esta fila que
son el cromo y el cobre porque no se
llenan exactamente así pero pueden
buscarlos por su parte entonces aquí
tenemos la configuración electrónica del
átomo de zinc en su estado fundamental
ahora otra forma en la que podemos
escribir esto sería escribiendo la
configuración electrónica del argón y
después escribimos 4s 23 de 10 vamos a
hacer lo primero llenamos 1s 2 vamos a
escribirlo 1s 2 y después si nos movemos
a la segunda fila tenemos 2 s 2 y luego
1 2 3 4 5 6 2p 6 entonces 2s 226 déjenme
escribir eso 2 s 2
y después cuando pasamos a la tercera
fila bueno si todo esto es muy extraño
para ustedes los invito a que vean los
vídeos en khan academy sobre
configuración electrónica entonces
después tenemos 3s 23 p 6 vamos a llenar
esas 2 sub capas 3 s 2 3
ok esta es la configuración electrónica
que corresponde al argón entonces
después tenemos 4 s 2 y 3 de 10 4 s 2 y
3 de 10
cualquiera de las dos formas puede
funcionar ahora pasemos a la segunda
parte de que sus nivel son retirados los
electrones cuando un átomo de zinc en
estado fundamental es oxidado bueno esto
es lo más interesante sobre los
elementos del bloque d es cómo construir
de electrón por electrón y así llenamos
la capa 4 s 2 pero después vamos a
regresar a llenar la capa 3 de porque
resulta que cuando tenemos un átomo de
zinc neutro los electrones de mayor
energía es decir los que son más fáciles
de retirar del átomo de zinc no son los
electrones d sino los electrones 4 s 2
entonces de qué sub nivel son retirados
los electrones bueno los que serán más
fáciles de retirar son los electrones 4s
y entonces los del subnivel
sub nivel 4 s
4 s
y los invito a que lean un poco más
sobre esto si es que tienen curiosidad
pueden imaginarlo en su cabeza aún
cuando analizamos los niveles de energía
el subnivel 3d y 4s están muy muy cerca
pero resulta que la mayor parte del
tiempo los que reaccionan son los que
están más alejados en este caso los 4 s
podemos decir que están en el nivel más
alto de energía y entonces cuando ocurre
la oxidación empezamos a arrancar esos
electrones del zinc es decir retiramos
esos electrones 4s